[Music]
what can i say fellas when i leave
you'll be missed
[Applause]
beautiful olga will you let me hold you
you go first
[Music]
attention attention dear comrades the
people city council informs you that due
to an incident at the turnabout nuclear
power plant there is an adverse
radioactive situation in the city of
pripya
[Music]
the reactor is in a sub-critical state
as you all know if enough fuel burns
through and gets to the water there will
be a steam explosion full of radioactive
material the contamination of
uncontained will spread to kiev moscow
and all of western europe
right so we have to get the water out
the volunteers will receive payment
[Music]
we're talking dirty water in a confined
space not a clean swimming pool all your
engineers just won't cut it
i'm going back down you won't survive
again
we have no authority to order it
do you really want to risk the citizens
of kiev getting ready for the mayday
celebration
in
[Music]
[Music]
you